The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational
resources for free.
To make a donation or view
additional materials from
hundreds of MIT courses, visit
MIT OpenCourseWare at
ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: Last Tuesday, we
ended up the lecture talking
about knapsack problems.
We talked about the continuous
knapsack problem and the fact
that you could solve
that optimally
with a greedy algorithm.
And we looked at the 0-1
knapsack problem and discussed
the fact that while we could
write greedy algorithms that
would solve the problem quickly,
we have to be careful
what we mean by "solve," and
that while those algorithms
would choose a set of items
that we could indeed carry
away, there was no guarantee
that it would choose the
optimal items, that is to say,
one that would meet the
objective function of maximizing
the value.
We looked after that at a brute
force algorithm on the
board only for finding an
optimal solution, a guaranteed
optimal solution, but observed
the fact that on even a
moderately sized set of
items, it might take a
decade or so to run.
Decided that wasn't very good.
Nevertheless, I want to start
today looking at some code
that implements a brute force
algorithm, not because I
expect anyone to actually run
this on a real example, but
because a bit later in the term,
we'll see how we could
modify this to something that
would be practical.
And there's some things to
learn by looking at it.
So let's look at
some code here.
I don't expect you to understand
in real time all
the details of this code.
It's more I want you to
understand the basic idea
behind it and then the
result we get.
So you'll remember that we
looked at the complexity by
saying well, really, it's
like binary numbers.
So the first helper subroutine
I'm going to use is something
that generates binary numbers.
So it takes an n, some natural
number, and the number of
digits and returns a binary
string of that length,
representing the decimal
number n.
Why am I giving it this
number of digits?
Because I need to zero pad it.
If I want to have a vector that
represents whether or not
I take items, if I take only one
item, say the first one, I
don't want just a binary spring
with one digit in it.
Because I need all those zeros
to indicate that I'm not
taking the other items.
And so the second argument tells
me, in effect, how many
zeros I'm going to need.
And there's nothing mysterious
about the way it does it.
OK.
The next helper function
generates the
power set of the items.
What is a power set?
If you take a set, you can then
ask the question what are
all the subsets of the set?
What's the smallest
subset of a set?
It's the empty set.
No items.
What's the largest
subset of a set?
All of the items.
And then we have everything in
between, the set that contains
the first item, the set that
contains the second item, et
cetera, the set that contains
the first and the second, the
first and the third.
There are a lot of them.
And of course, how
many is a lot?
Well, 2 to the n is a lot.
But now we're going
to generate every
possible subset of items.
And we're going to do this
simply using the decimal to
binary function to tell us
whether or not we keep each
one, so we can enumerate them.
We can generate them all.
And now we have the set of all
possible items one might take,
irrespective of whether they
obey the constraint of not
weighing too much.
The next function is the
one that does the work.
This is the interesting one.
Choose best.
It takes a power set, the
constraint, and two functions.
One, getValue--
it tells me the value
of an item.
And the other getWeight--
it tells me the weight
of an item.
Then it just goes through.
And it enumerates all
possibilities
and eventually chooses--
I won't say the best
set, because it
might not be unique.
There might be more than
one optimal answer.
But it finds at least
And then it returns that.
Again it's a very
straightforward implementation
of the brute force algorithm
I sketched on the board.
And then we can run it with
testBest, which is going to
build the items using
the function we
looked at last time.
It's then going to get the
power set of the items.
It's going to call chooseBest
and then print the result.
So let's see what happens
if we run it.
We get an error.
Oh dear.
I hadn't expected that.
And it says test-- oh testBest
is not defined.
All right.
Let's try that again.
Sure looks like it's
defined to me.
There it is.
OK.
And you may recall that this
is a better answer than
anything that was generated
by the greedy
algorithm on Tuesday.
You may not recall it,
but believe me it is.
It happened to have found
a better solution.
And not surprisingly, that's
because I contrived the
example to make sure
that would happen.
Why does it work better in the
sense-- or why does it find a
better answer?
Why might it find
a better answer?
Well, because the greedy
algorithm chose something that
was locally optimal
at each step.
But there was no guarantee that
a sequence of locally
optimal decisions would reach
a global optimum.
What this algorithm does is it
finds a global optimum by
looking at all solutions.
And that's something we'll see
again and again, as we go
forward, that there's always a
temptation to do things one
step at a time, finding
local optimum--
optima--
because it's fast.
It's easy.
But there's no guarantee
it will work well.
Now the problem, of course,
with finding the global
optimum is, as we discussed, it
is prohibitively expensive.
Now you could ask is it
prohibitively expensive
because I chose a stupid
algorithm,
the brute force algorithm?
Well, it is a stupid
algorithm.
But in fact, this is a problem
that is what we would call
inherently exponential.
We've looked at this
concept before.
That in addition to talking
about the complexity of an
algorithm, we can talk about the
complexity of a problem in
which we ask the question how
fast can the absolute best
solution, fastest solution
to this problem, be?
And here you can construct a
mathematical proof that says
the problem is inherently
exponential.
No matter what we do, we're not
going to be able to find
something that's guaranteed to
find the optimal, that is
faster than exponential.
Well, now let's be careful
of that statement.
What that means is the worst
case is inherently
exponential.
As we will see in a couple of
weeks-- it'll take us a while
to get there--
there are actually algorithms
that people use to solve these
inherently exponential problems
and solve them fast
enough to be useful.
So, for example, when you go
to look at airline fares on
Kayak to try and find the best
fare from A to B, it is an
inherently exponential problem,
but you get an answer
pretty quickly.
And that's because there are
techniques you can use.
Now, in fact, one of the reasons
you get it is they
don't guarantee that
you actually
get an optimal solution.
But there are techniques that
guarantee to give you an
optimal solution that almost all
the time will run quickly.
And we'll look at one of those
a bit later in the term.
Before we do that, however, I
want to leave for a while the
whole question of complexity
behind and look at another
class of optimization
problems.
We'll look at several
different kinds of
optimization problems as
the term goes forward.
The kind I want to look at today
is probably what I would
say is the most exciting
branch of
computer science today.
And of course I might
have a bias.
And that's machine learning.
It's a word you'll
hear a lot about.
And it's a technique that
many of you will apply.
You might not write
your own codes.
But I guarantee you were either
be the beneficiary or
the victim of machine learning
almost every time you log on
to the web these days.
I should probably start
by defining what
machine learning is.
But that's hard to do.
I really don't know
how to do it.
Superficially, you could say
that machine learning deals
with the question of how to
build programs that learn.
However, I think in a very real
sense every program we
write learns something.
If I implement Newton's method,
it's learning what the
roots of the polynomial is.
Certainly when we looked
at curve fitting--
fitting curves to data--
we were learning a model
of the data.
That's what that
regression is.
Wikipedia says--
and of course, it must be true
if Wikipedia says it--
that machine learning is a
scientific discipline that is
concerned with the design and
development of algorithms that
allow computers to evolve
behaviors based
on empirical data.
I'm not sure how helpful
this definition is.
But it was the best
I could find.
And it doesn't really matter.
But it sort of gets at the issue
that a major focus of
machine learning research is
to automatically learn to
recognize complex patterns and
make intelligent decisions
based on data.
This whole process is something
called inductive inference.
The basic idea is
one observes--
actually one doesn't.
The program observes examples
that represent an incomplete
information about some
statistical phenomena and then
tries to generate a model, just
like with curve fitting,
that summarizes some statistical
properties of that
data and can be used to predict
the future, for
example, give you information
about unseen data.
There are roughly speaking two
distinctive approaches to
machine learning called
supervised learning and
unsupervised learning.
Let's first talk about
supervised learning.
It's a little easier to
appreciate how it might work.
In supervised learning, we
associate a label with each
example in a training set.
So think of that as an answer
to a query about an example.
If the label is discrete,
we typically call it a
classification problem.
So we would try and classify,
for example, a transaction on
a credit card as belonging to
the owner of that credit card
or not belonging to the owner,
as i.e., with some
probability, a stolen
credit card.
So it's discrete.
It belongs to the owner.
It doesn't belong
to the owner.
If the labels are real valued,
we think of it as
a regression problem.
And so indeed, when we did the
curve fitting, we were doing
machine learning.
And we were handling a
regression problem.
Based on the examples from the
training set, the goal is to
build a program that can predict
the answer for other
cases before they were
explicitly observed.
So we're trying to generalize
from the statistical
properties of a training set to
be able to make predictions
about things we haven't seen.
Let's look at an example.
So here, I've got red
and blue circles.
And I'm trying to learn what
makes a circle red or what's
the difference between red and
blue, other than the color?
Think of my information as the
(x,y) values and the label as
the color, red or blue.
So I've labeled each one.
And now I'm trying to
learn something.
Well, it's kind of tricky.
What are the questions I need to
answer to think about this?
And then we'll look at
how we might do it.
So, a first question
I need to ask is
are the labels accurate?
And in fact, in a lot of real
world examples, in most real
world examples, there's
no guarantee that
the labels are accurate.
So you have to assume that
well, maybe some of
the labels are wrong.
How do we deal with that?
Perhaps the most fundamental
question is the past
representative of the future?
We've seen many examples where
people have learned things,
for example, to predict
the price of housing.
And it turns out you hit some
singularity which means the
past is not a very good
predictor of the future.
And even if all of your learning
is good, you get the
wrong answer.
So you sort of always have
to ask that question.
Do you have enough data
to generalize?
And by this, I mean enough
training data.
If your training set is very
small, you shouldn't have a
lot of confidence in
what you learn.
A big issue here is feature
extraction.
As we'll see when we look at
real examples, the world is a
pretty complex place.
And we need to decide what
features we're going to use.
If I were to ask 25% of you to
come up in the front of the
room and then try and separate
you based upon some feature--
if I were to say, all right, I'm
going to separate the good
students from the bad students,
but the only
features I have available are
the clothes you're wearing, it
might not work so well.
And very importantly, how
tight should the fit be?
So now let's go back to
our example here.
We can look at two different
ways we might
generalize from this data.
And indeed, when we're looking
at classification problems in
supervised learning, what
we're typically doing is
trying to find some way of
dividing our training data.
In this case, I've given you a
two-dimensional projection.
As we'll see, it's not always
two-dimensional.
It's not usually
So I might choose this rather
eccentric shape
and say that's great.
And why is that great?
It's great because it minimizes
training error.
So if we look at it as an
optimization problem, we might
say that our objective function
is how many points
are correctly classified
in the training
data as red or blue.
And this triangular shape
has no training error.
Every point is perfectly
classified in
the training data.
If I choose this linear
separator instead, I have some
training error.
This red point is misclassified
in the training.
Does that mean that
the triangle is
better than the line?
Not necessarily, right?
Because my goal is to predict
future points.
And maybe that's mislabeled
or an experimental error.
Maybe it's accurately labeled
but an outlier, very unusual.
And this will not
generalize well.
This is analogous to what we
talked about as overfitting
when we looked at
curve fitting.
And that's-- a very big problem
in machine learning is
if you overfit to your training
data, it might not
generalize well and might
give you bogus
answers going forward.
OK.
So that's a very quick look
at supervised learning.
We'll come back to that.
I now want to talk about
unsupervised learning.
The big difference here is we
have training data, but we
don't have labels.
So I just give you a
bunch of points.
It's as if we looked at this
picture, and I didn't tell you
which were the red points and
which were the blue points.
They were just all points.
So what can I learn?
What typically you're learning
in unsupervised learning, is
you're learning about
regularities of the data.
So if we looked at this and
think away the red and the
blue, we might well say well,
at least, if I look at this,
there is some structure
to this data.
And maybe what I should do
is divide it this way.
It gives me kind of a nice
clean separation.
But maybe I should divide
it this way.
Or maybe I should put
a circle around each
of these four groupings.
Complicated, what to do.
But what we see is there is
clearly some structure here.
And the idea of unsupervised
learning is to
discover that structure.
Far and away, the dominant form
of unsupervised learning
is clustering.
And that's what I was just
talking about, is finding the
cluster in this data.
So we'll move forward here.
There it is, with everything
the same color.
But here I've labeled
the x- and y-axes
as height and weight.
What does clustering mean?
It's the process of organizing
the objects or the points into
groups whose members are
similar in some way.
A key issue is what do
we mean by similar?
What's the metric
we want to use?
And we can see that here.
If I tell you that,
really, I want to
cluster people by height--
say, people are similar if
they're the same height--
then it's pretty clear how I
should divide this, right,
what my clusters should be.
My clusters should probably be
this group of shorter people
and this group of
taller people.
If I tell you I'm interested
in weight, then probably I
want a cluster it with the
divisor here between the
heavier people and the
lighter people.
Or if I say well, I'm interested
in some combination
of those two, then maybe I'll
get four clusters as I
discussed before.
Clustering algorithms are
used all over the place.
For example, in marketing,
they're used to find groups of
customers with similar
behavior.
Walmart is famous for using that
clustering to find that.
They did a clustering to
determine when people bought
the same thing.
And then they would rearrange
their shelves to encourage
people to buy things.
And sort of the most famous
example they discovered was
there was a strong correlation
between people between people
who bought beer and people
who bought diapers.
And so there was a period
where if you walked in a
Walmart store, you would find
the beer and the diapers next
to each other.
And I leave it to you
to speculate on
why that was true.
It just happened to be
true in Walmart.
Amazon uses clustering to find
people who like similar books.
So every time you buy a book on
Amazon, they're running a
clustering algorithm to find
out who looks like you.
Said, oh, this person
looks just like you.
So if they buy a book, maybe
you'll get an email suggesting
you buy that book or the next
time you log into Amazon.
Or when you look at a book, they
tell you here are some
similar books.
And then they've done a
clustering to group books as
similar based on
buying habits.
Netflix uses that to recommend
movies, et cetera.
Biologists spend a lot of time
these days doing clustering.
They classify plants or animals
based on their features.
We'll shortly see an example
of that, as in right after
Patriot's Day.
But they also use it
a lot in genetics.
So clustering is used to try and
find genes that look like
or groups of genes.
Insurance companies use that to
decide how much to charge
you for your automobile
insurance.
They cluster drivers based
upon-- and use that to predict
who's going to have
an accident.
Document classification on the
web is used all the time.
It's used a lot in medicine.
Just used all over the place.
So what is it exactly?
Well the nice thing is
we can define it very
straightforwardly as an
optimization problem.
And so we can ask what
properties does a good
clustering have?
Well, it should have low
intra-cluster dissimilarity.
So in a good clustering, all
of the points in the same
cluster should be similar, by
whatever metric you're using
for similarity.
As we'll see, there are a
lot of choices there.
But that's not enough.
We'd also like to have high
inter-cluster dissimilarity.
So we'd like the points within
a cluster to be a lot like
each other.
But if points are in different
clusters, we'd like them to be
quite different from
each other.
That tells us that we
have a good cluster.
All right, let's look at it.
How might we model
dissimilarity?
Well, using a concept we've
already seen-- variance.
So we can talk about the
variance of some cluster C as
equal to the sum of all elements
x in C, of the mean
of C minus x squared.
Or maybe we can take the square
root of it, if we want.
But it's exactly the idea we've
seen before, right?
Then we say what's the average
value of the cluster?
And then we look at how far is
each point from the average.
We sum them.
And that tells us how
much variance we
have within the cluster.
Make sense?
So that's variance.
So we can use that to talk
about how similar or
dissimilar the elements
in the cluster are.
We can use the same idea to
compare points in separate
clusters and compute various
different ways-- and we'll
look at different ways--
to look at the distance
between clusters.
So combining these two things,
we could get, say, a metric
we'll call badness--
not a technical word.
And now I'll ask the question
is the optimization problem
that we're solving
in clustering
finding a set of clusters--
capital C--
such that badness of that set
of clusters is minimized?
Is that a sufficient definition
of the problem
we're trying to solve?
Find a set of clusters
C, such that the
badness of C is minimized.
is that good enough?
AUDIENCE: No.
PROFESSOR: No, why not?
AUDIENCE: Just imagine a case
where you view cluster-- if
you make a single cluster,
every cluster has
one element in it.
And the variance is 0.
PROFESSOR: Exactly.
So that has a trivial solution,
which is probably
not the one we want,
of putting each
point in its own cluster.
Badness--
it won't be bad.
It'll be a perfect clustering
in some sense.
But it doesn't do us
any good really.
So what do we do to fix that?
What do we usually do
when we formulate an
optimization problem?
What's missing?
I've given you the objective
function.
What have I not giving you?
AUDIENCE: Constraints.
PROFESSOR: A constraint.
So we need to add some
constraint here that will
prevent us from finding
a trivial solution.
So what kind of constraints
might we look at?
There are different
ways of doing it.
A couple of ones
that is usual.
Sometimes you might have as a
constraint, the maximum number
of clusters.
Say, all right, cluster my data,
but I want at most K
clusters --
10 clusters.
That would be my constraint,
like the weight for the
knapsack problem.
Or maybe I'll want to put
something on the maximum
distance between clusters.
So I don't want the distance
between any two clusters to be
more than something.
In general, solving this
optimization problem is
computationally prohibitive.
So once again, in practice, what
people typically resort
to is greedy algorithms.
And I want to look at two kinds
of greedy algorithms,
probably the two most common
approaches to clustering.
One is called k-means.
In k-means clustering, you say
I want exactly k clusters.
And find the best
k clustering.
We'll talk about how
it does that.
And again, it's not guaranteed
to find the best.
And the other is hierarchical
clustering.
We'll come back to
that shortly.
Both are simple to understand
and widely used in practice.
So let's first talk about
how we do this.
Let's first look at hierarchical
clustering.
So we have a set of n items
to be clustered.
And let's assume we have an n
by n distance matrix that
tells me for each pair of items
how far they are from
each other.
So we can look at an example.
So here's an n by n distance
matrix for the airline
distance between some cities
in the United States.
The distance from Boston
to Boston is 0 miles.
Distance from New York is 206.
The distance from Chicago
to San Francisco
is 2,142, et cetera.
All right?
So I have my n by n distance
matrix there.
Now let's go through how
hierarchical clustering would
relate these things
to each other.
So we start by assigning each
item to its own cluster.
So if we have n items, we
now have n clusters.
All right?
That's the trivial solution
that you suggested before.
The next step is to find the
most similar pair of clusters
and merge them.
So if we look here and we just--
we start, we'll have
six clusters, one
for each city.
And we would merge the two most
similar, which I guess in
this case is New York
and Boston.
Hard to believe that those are
the most similar cities.
But at least by this distance
metric they're the closest.
So we would merge those two.
And then you just continue the
process in principle, until
all items are in one cluster.
So now you have a whole
hierarchy of clusters.
And you can cut it off
where you want.
If you want to have six
clusters, you could look at
where the hierarchy
you have six.
You can look where you have
two, where you have three.
Of course, you don't have to go
all the way to finish it if
you don't want to.
This kind of hierarchical
clustering is called
agglomerative.
Why?
Well, because we're
combining things.
We're agglomerating them.
So this is pretty
straightforward, except for two.
The complication in step (2) is
we have to define what it
means to find the two most
similar clusters.
Now it's pretty easy when the
clusters each contain one
element, because, well, we
have our metric-- in this
case, distance--
and we can just do
that as I did.
But it's not so obvious
what you do when they
have multiple elements.
And in fact, different metrics
can be used to get different
properties.
So I want to talk about
some of the
metrics we use for that.
These are typically called
linkage criteria.
So one popular one is what's
called single linkage.
It's also called
connectedness, or minimum method.
In this, we consider the
distance between a pair of
clusters to be equal to the
shortest distance from any
member to any other member.
So we take the two points in
each cluster that are closest
to each other and say
that's the distance
between the two clusters.
People also use something called
complete linkage--
It's also called diameter
or maximum--
where we consider the distance
between any two clusters to be
the distance between the points
that are furthest from
each other.
So in one case, essentially
single linkages was looking at
the best case.
Complete--
in English, not French--
is looking at the worst case.
And you won't be surprised to
hear that you could also look
at the average case, where you
take all of the distances.
So you take all of the
pairwise things.
You add them up.
You take the average.
You can also take the mean, the
median, if you want instead.
None of these is necessarily
best.
But they do give you
different answers.
And so I want to look at that
now with our example here.
So let's look at
it and run it.
So the first step is independent
of what linkage
we're using.
We get these six clusters.
All right, now let's look
at the second step.
Well, also pretty simple
since we only have one
element in each one.
We're going to get
that clustering.
All right.
Now, what about the next step?
What do I get if I'm
using the minimal
single linkage distance?
What gets merged here?
Somebody?
AUDIENCE: Boston, New
York and Chicago.
PROFESSOR: Boston, New
York, and Chicago.
And it turns out we'll get the
same thing if we use other
linkages in this case.
Let's continue to
the next step.
Now we'll end up merging San
Francisco and Seattle.
Now we get a difference.
What does the red represent
and what
does the blue represent?
Which linkage criteria?
We're saying, we could either
merge Denver with Boston, New
York, and Chicago.
Or we could merge Denver with
San Francisco and Seattle.
Which is which?
Which linkage criterion has put
Denver in which cluster?
Well, suppose we're using
single linkage.
Where are we getting it from?
AUDIENCE: Boston, New
York and Chicago?
PROFESSOR: Yes.
Because it's not so
far from Chicago.
Even though it's pretty far
from Boston or New York.
But if we use average linkage,
we see on average, it's closer
to San Francisco and Seattle
than it is to the average of
Boston, New York, or Chicago.
So we get a different answer.
And then finally, at
the last step,
everything gets merged together.
So you can see, in this case,
without having labels, we have
used a feature to produce things
and, say, if we wanted
to have three clusters, we
would maybe stop here.
And we'd say, all right, these
things are one cluster.
This is a cluster.
And this is a cluster.
And that's not a bad
geographical clustering,
actually, for deciding
how to relate these
things to each other.
This technique is used a lot.
It does have some weaknesses.
One weakness is it's very
time consuming.
It doesn't scale well.
The complexity is at least order
n-squared, where n is
the number of points
to be clustered.
And in fact, in many
implementations, it's worse
than n-squared.
And of course, it doesn't
necessarily find the optimal
clustering, even giving
these criteria.
It might never at any level have
the optimal clustering,
because, again, at each step,
it's making a locally optimal
decision, not guaranteed to
find the best solution.
I should point out that a big
issue in deciding to get these
clusters or getting
these clusters was
my choice of features.
And this is something we're
going to come back to in
spades, because I actually think
it is the most important
issue in machine learning--
is if we're going to say which
points are similar to each
other, we need to understand
our feature space.
So, for example, the feature
I'm using here
is distance by air.
Suppose, instead, I added
distance by air and distance
by road and distance by train.
Well, particularly given this
sparsity of railroads in this
country, we might get very
different clustering,
depending upon where
the trains ran.
And suppose I throw in a totally
different feature like
population.
Well, I might get another
different clustering,
depending on how I use that.
What we typically need to do in
these situations, dealing
with multi-dimensional data--
and most data is
multi-dimensional--
is we construct something called
a feature vector that
incorporates multiple
features.
So we might have
for each city--
we'll just take something
like the distance.
Or let's say, instead of
distance, we'll compute the
distance by having for each
city its GPS coordinates,
where it is on the globe,
and its population.
And let's say that's how
we define a city.
And that would be our
feature vector.
And then we would cluster it,
say, using hierarchical
clustering to determine which
cities are most like which
other cities.
Well, it's a little
bit complicated.
I have to ask how do I compare
feature vectors?
What distance metric
do I use there?
Do I get confused that GPS
coordinates and populations
are essentially unrelated?
And I wouldn't like to compare
those to each other.
Lots of issues there, and that's
what we're going to
talk about when we come back
from Patriot's Day--
is how in the real world
problems, we go from the large
number of features associated
with objects or things in the
real world to feature vectors
that allow us to automatically
deduce which things are
quote "most similar"
to which other things.